in the midst of or just after their
dramatic release of the State Department
cables I got a call from mark Schmucker
former co-chairman of universal and he
said would you like to do this and I
left at it I mean it came in an
inconvenient time I was doing some other
stuff but I thought I can I can't not do
this it's such an important story and at
the time I thought it was about two
things I thought it was a simple David
and Goliath story meaning Julian Assange
against the US government and I thought
it was about a leaking machine this
electronic dropbox and that was going to
be very interesting it ended up being
something very different I mean Julian's
character changed i discovered the
character bradley manning threw out it
became a much more important figure and
also rather than being about a leaking
machine and ended up being a story about
human relationships in the time of the
internet and that you know was also a
very interesting revelation so it you
know the the scope of it changed very
much as we were pursuing the story so as
Bradley story started to discover that
how did you go about packaging it all
together well we wanted the back and
forth between Bradley and Julian the
problem we had I mean in addition to the
fact that the Julian didn't want to talk
to me or at least he didn't want to do
an on-camera interview I had a character
who was in prison and the United States
government had no interest in letting
the atom so how would I present Bradley
Manning's character I mean not going to
talk to other people about him but in
the course of making the film another
batch of these initial chats with
Adrienne mama were released by Wired
magazine and when we saw that second
batch sort of the full portrait of
Bradley's character came through and we
thought we'll wait a minute maybe we can
rather than getting an actor to read
them or whatever we can actually show
them as he saw them as Adrian lamo saw
them that is to say to print them and
that led us down a road of trying to
build into the film a whole sort of
graph
component but also to have this a
character that would exist primarily
through the chats that he wrote down on
his computer that seemed to be a very
intriguing idea and we were terrified at
first as the whether or not this would
work but over time we got the feeling
that actually it was getting at a kind
of intimacy and it's a funny kind of
intimacy because it's at once very
isolating and intimate all at the same
time and of course he was communicating
with a complete stranger I got involved
early on I suspected that because so
much of this story would be about the
internet and it became much more about
the Internet in a way not only about
secrets what should be secret which
should not be secret the surveillance
state and all of that but also about how
we're all being changed by the internet
so I wanted to somehow find a way to to
make that come alive on screen and I
formed a partnership with this company
called frame store which is a you know
very well known graphics company they do
a lot of title sequences that had the
special effects were harry potter and
the new york office in particular wanted
to become involved at an early stage to
be able to get involved in the story
from the beginning so that you know very
often when i work with a graphics
company they come in at the end and you
go through this process where they
always show you beautiful stuff but it's
very often inappropriate for the story
so they were involved with a story from
the beginning and so particularly with
these chats we work very long and hard
to try to give them a character that
wasn't just printed characters on a
screen but they they felt like they were
emanating from the screen and there was
something both handmade and computer ish
about them that would give the character
of these two characters who communicate
only by text you know a sense of
humanity do you think that if you had a
sit-down interview with Julian on screen
with that how do you think that would
have changed the story if at all I was
given this assignment at a time when
Julian had become an incredibly famous
person and by the time I approached him
and one of my executive producers was
one of his was one of the people
actually put up some of the money for
his bail so I was plugged right in to
his camp
but he was already surrounded by agents
and lawyers and hangers-on and political
activists so he had become a kind of
human commodity the more I learned about
Julian and I did meet him a number of
times but a more I learned about through
other people the more convinced I wanted
to find out and find a way to portray
him prior to when he became famous and I
established a relationship with this
wonderful Australian filmmaker Mark
Davis who had followed him with just
himself in a camera and a little mic on
the camera and gotten all this wonderful
footage of Julian before he was famous
and that gives a flavor of the character
of a more idealistic person who's who's
who's in search of a dream but hasn't
yet found it